savez le jeudi cette partie d'émission
c'est les questions 4/3 de jean luc
lemoine c'est parti alors on a de
nombreux nouveaux téléspectateurs et
bien sachez le jean luc lemoine s'occupe
de l'équipe en fait et trouvent des
casseroles qui se passe pendant
l'émission qui se passe aussi entre les
pauses un point dans la pub pendant les
pauses voilà deux magnétos il se passe
beaucoup de choses dans cette émission
se passe autant de choses à l'antenne à
caen demain on à l'antenne sur tout ce
côté là un jean michel lemaire tout ça
c'était très prolifique de ce côté là
oui c'est ça toujours aller tout de
suite une question alors bonjour je
m'appelle françoise j'ai lu que jérémy
ferrari et annie lemoine parti chez
ruquier
donc je voulais savoir si cyril hanouna
comptait se débarrasser d'autres
personnes ou si les gars d'études et
autres boules et sas ont chacun fait ce
qu'il veut
non c'est juste qu'on finit des
émissions et puis après on a gardé en
janvier qui sera là j'aimerais vous
répondre hier françoise mais je ne sais
pas cyril va-t-il garder tout le monde
j'espère que non mais la décision ne
m'appartient pas déjà personnellement je
me débarrasse serait bien de tirer mort
aux rats qui je le pense sincèrement ne
m'aime pas je m'en suis rendu compte au
moment de notre présentation par cyril
regarder que ce soit et nora au moins il
est toujours aussi enthousiaste
solide
il a un problème avec jean-luc je le
pense dans le crâne en bleu vous le
craignez c'est pour ça que tu applaudis
pas si tu me criait tu m'as peut dire
est beaucoup c'est moche un vrai mental
et franchement dans ce cas là je préfère
que tu applaudissent parce que - blesson
mais bon c'est peut-être une absence un
nom va vérifier vendredi dernier jeu je
présentais comme je pouvais je vous
remplacer l'émission vous le présentez
très bien merci vous êtes formidables et
vous êtes très bien c'est très joli le
gris merci
voilà c'est devenu equallogic mais moi
je pars pas en week end avec vous vous
coûter beaucoup trop cher donc je
présentais et thierry a tout de suite eu
un petit geste d'encouragement
moi qui pensais que c'était mon ami
ce n'est pas d'hier mais l'image de
valérie écran un peu philippe jean luc
le mec que les panneaux même pas qui est
cette personne
mon prénom c'est plus la méchanceté
c'est du mépris mais je suis dégoûté
j'aimerais tellement voulu qu'on est
chez pas moi la même complicité que ces
pages et gilles verdez et jean michel mr
a parce que les deux alors je peux vous
dire c'est quand ils sont côte à côte
c'est la grosse éclate
c'est le ski de fond
ce travail
j'avais vraiment bon
il est livré voulais me trois ans plus
tard et plus de
j'ai pas voulu
le
le plus simple
copé si ça vous intéresse est pas bon
non mais jean-michel n'est pas une fille
facile il est fidèle à thierry moreau il
est même possessif
regardez le camp sont titi veut prêter
un stylo à valérie
c'est pourquoi des derniers mois la
demande et c'est qu'il y aurait 400 ans
mais le duo dans les cas tient le mec et
satellisé tu sais c'est une star et vous
savez pourquoi jean michel n'aime pas
quand thierry prêter stylo à quelqu'un
d'autre
bah pas ce qui peut plus travailler et
faire des chiens obtint taper testino
c'est wagne sétois café ça je te
félicite pas bien sûr c'est mon choix je
pense que l'habitat patoche ses marques
et en plus
deux jours l'habitat pah tolosane en bas
c'est bon d'avoir des prix nobel dans
l'équipe non mais de toute façon
personne ne peut nier entre thierry jean
michel valery essayé une fois et on
était très heureuse enfin au début
regardez l'évolution
là c'est drôle d'être entre bout de la
moi ça me fait très plaisir
pour m primo que son courrier en même
temps je suis pas cela on lui prend la
main pour problème tout moment d'avoir
tout vol valérie qui subit beaucoup dans
cette émission puisque quand ce ne sont
pas pipés mario c'est cyril non notre
leader notre gourou notre notre
phénomène votre phénomène qui viendra
coiffer il est si créatif
laissez jamais dû faire après chig avec
les dom enora tu connais le breton
regardez ce que j'ai fait à bras dans l
économie
si c'est pas moi je me reconnais dans je
ne me reconnais pas le breda nombreux
dans chaque point de vue pénal on peut
pas jouer serré car il est irresponsable
et on lui pardonne tout cas il est
tellement doué la semaine dernière de
recevions laurent ournac et sylvie
tellier et laurent va faire une blague
d'entrée en disant ah c'est bien de
recevoir deux femmes enceintes ensemble
c'est drôle sauf si quelqu'un lui répond
vous en faites pas ça vous va bien vous
est-ce que siri sur est capable de faire
une bourde pareille
regardez l'escroc comment il va se
rattraper
jean paquet sur une vanne directement
exister sympa de recevoir deux femmes
enceintes en même temps homme a été mis
sur pied
c'est louis de funès
il fait beau gosse leçon ya deux
semaines je vous ai montré ce qui était
le jeu sans ballon vous savez cette
capacité qu'ont les chroniqueurs a
participé sans jamais réussir à prendre
la parole
alors je pensais que c'était isabelle
morini-bosc la plus forte mais j'ai
trouvé mieux
thierry moreau à huy qui lui a une
particularité il écoute en ruminant
c'est pourquoi
je suis marque plus il me regarde pas
même avec les yeux de l'amour
je sais ça aille le vit à fond mr bean
merci les amoureux et nora et plus
efficace en jeu sans ballon est très
très clair en un seul mot même quand
elle parle tout seul on la comprend très
bien on va parler de ce qui va se passer
dans un instant y aura le jeu dame je
mate sur krim à l'émission de gilles
deux n 1 jean marc morandini c'est avec
l'émission oui c'est vrai je le dis
c'est vrai que moi je regarde crime tous
les lundis soirs poule je pense que
parler de l'animal jean michel est aussi
très fort on écoute passive même très
passive puisque lui quand il est
concentré il n'est pas concentré il fait
des micro sieste
mais la pluie
comment se fait il faudrait qu'il se
repose un peu jean michel mais non il
peut pas s'en empêcher il faut toujours
qu'ils bossent jeudi dernier ils
n'étaient pas dans l'émission ben c'est
parce qu'ils étaient en séminaire à la
montagne la wii en tant que consultant
média pour eurosport bon bon il était au
ski et bien sache que tu as beaucoup
manqué à tes voisins regardent fondue
raclette
je vais lui envoyer un sms tiens un truc
de beauf ça montrera clemi sera
magnifique
ça paraît que c'est pas gentil ça j'en
échelle et très endurant il nous l'a
bien prouvé lors du défi rap si vous
souvenez du défi rap avec franck dubosc
et devait lire un texte en un temps
donné
juste pour rappel le record de franck
dubosc un petit rappel attention jean
michel c'est à vous à voir si vous
battez franck dubosc c'est parti on
aimerait bien que le chrono par jamie
débouche sur un cahier j'ai mis des mots
que j'écris j'espère bien me février
j'ai eu des manques du triez j'ai mis
des boudoirs des courriers ou des
émotions c'est pareil oui alors comme
nous sommes à la pointe de la
technologie le chrono s'est enrayée et
c'est ça qui rend la suite pathétique
parce que le seul qui n'a pas vu ça
c'est jean-michel il va continuer dans
son délire jusqu'à croire qu'il a battu
le record
pourquoi pas le problème c'est qu'il n'a
pas le triomphe modeste donc il a
manifesté son bonheur un peu trop un peu
comme un mec qui pensent avoir qu'un but
enlève son maillot fait le tour du stade
on aurait alors que tout le monde sait
qu'il est hors jeu armée alors au final
que faut-il retenir de la séquence qui
va suivre que quand il parle vite
jean michel devient au fil rouge qu un
furoncle et quand il est content il
transpire sous les bras mais les mots un
peu partout raising en partie minées moi
je pensais me géminées mots j'ai jamais
trop aimé trois micros j'ai mis des mots
j'ai vu l'incroyable nouvelle on
retrouve
non mais vous le pardonner parce que si
son truc le rap
oui un des tubes de l'émission c'est
bella week end de maitre gims et le
cirill connais par coeur tout comme
jean-michel ici regardez bonjour michel
les parle c'est facile à retenir c'est m
si vous aimez les chansons à texte et
karaoké c'est maintenant
m
mais on est tous et c'est encore plus
beau c'est parce qu'il a l'air un peu
dépressif comme il est et on écossais ça
prend une autre dimension
mais bon qui dit musique dit danse et
qui dix ans dit isabelle ah oui alors
j'ai enfin compris pourquoi et gigoter
tout le temps en fait et des gens qui
habitent dans sa tête ah s'il ya des
gens qui habitent dans sa tête et même
que des fois leur dit bonjour avec ses
doigts a finalement je crois je ne suis
pas sûr mais je crois qu'elle a des
puces il va pas voulu changer son
collier un aller comme c'est bientôt
noël je ne finis pas par une nouvelle
complice des danses de la calomnie des
tabourets à huy isabelle c'est à toi oui
j'aime bien
c'est bon
grossir
je pense
e
je goûte
et
c'est la fille cap al hadi était magique
et j'ai beaucoup aimé l'auto tamponneuse
voilà vous le faites souvent l'auto
tamponneuse s'est mariée ne s'arrêtent
jamais et où là une autre question
talent et pour finir à dire question
question bonjour je m'appelle jennifer
je voudrais savoir si jean michel maire
est toujours mac et parce que sinon
arrêtent de chercher bébé quand tu veux
je te fais sauter sur mes genoux
toujours baquet en battant vous me le
dites oui vous êtes toujours à kiwi
toujours cabaye s'est pas c'est pas une
tare non monsieur un jour avec la même
toujours qui s'appelle qui s'appelle
j j j j la lettre j s'appelle j c gêné
il encore il peut être à la fin que
jeanine avec josiane avec josette
royaume uni ferait des vertiges à lutter